[Applaudissements]
trois faisant d'une âme
une dame ont déclaré établir une
domination complète sur le veau d'éléphant grâce à
un mélange de punitions restreintes mais
aussi de récompenses, cela entraîne
des dommages physiques et psychologiques, mais
le but est de faire comprendre à l'éléphant
que désobéir aux gens est
douloureux
[Musique
] nous devons donc nous assurer qu'il s'agit de la dernière
génération d'éléphants utilisés pour
le tourisme commercial en captivité et
améliorer les conditions de ces éléphants
et des personnes impliquées pendant cette
phase d'élimination, par exemple en promouvant davantage de
tourisme basé uniquement sur l'observation où
ce risque d'interaction directe est  retiré
de l'équation